hey there friends so I got a question
for you where does stress live in your
body I asked this question CU I've got a
video to shoot today where I'm going to
be teaching a poy combo and I can feel
all of these places in my body where
I've been holding the stress from the
past week so I'm going to take you
through a little journey while I try to
work that stress out and maybe it'll
just inspire you to find ways to do the
same for yourself
Drex here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love of pois spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today we're going to be playing
around with those bodies a whole lot but
of course before we dive in I just want
to give a quick shout out to the Friends
of the channel big thanks to dark bunk
fire Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyrot teror light toys spinballs
and Ultra for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all these awesome companies
and the work they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non- business friend of the channel
Becca Becken thank you so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission so I'm sure that most of you
have probably seen that Meme that calls
all of us out in ways that makes us a
little uncomfortable and says hey you
yes you unclench your jaw stop touching
your tongue to the top of your mouth let
your shoulders out things like that
these are just a few of the ways that we
tend to hold stress in our bodies and my
goodness I know that I hold a lot of it
in my body don't you like I do the thing
where I clench my jaw I do the thing
where I touch my tongue to the top of my
mouth I usually wake up first thing in
the morning and discover that I've been
doing that all night I also hold a lot
of tension in my shoulders and as I've
been learning more about dance I've also
been discovering that I'm holding a lot
of that stress around in my hips I will
find at the end of the day that I've
been holding my legs together really
really hard as I've been working on
stuff I've been trying to find a better
chair to discourage me from doing that
and it hasn't been super successful just
yet and this is one of the reasons why I
really love dance because when I get
outside and Do My Dance warm-ups it
helps me activate those parts of my body
that have been holding that stress and
tension all that time and not only does
that help me get my body back in working
order but it also helps to relieve the
stress that's been stored there so
because I have to shoot a dance video
today anyway I figured I would take you
through my warm-up routine and talk a
little bit about all those places in my
body where I hold on to stress and the
exercises that I use to try and
dissipate it so I'm going to throw on
just a little bit of music but hopefully
keep it low enough that uh YouTube
doesn't give me a bunch of copyright
strikes on this keep your fingers
crossed on this one lately I've been
digging the top 40 I don't know maybe
just me cool we'll see if this shows up
in the audio once I can press it so one
thing I usually like starting off with
is an exercise where I do uh chass to
either side and and do pendulums going
back and forth between different timing
and Direction modes simply because it
gets me moving and it's almost like
starting off with some jumping jacks in
some ways so let's dive into
that I'm always a little stiff when I
start this off and I find if I repeat it
a few times I start to let go a little
bit and really just like let my body
kind of fall out to either side and it
becomes really really relaxing in a lot
of ways all right next up warming up my
uh legs and feet going to go ahead just
do some thread the needles as I lift up
my heels and warm up the arches of my
feet and then taking caps
overhead keeping my foot in Coupe next
to my ankle and then up to
Posay tand
across oh this feels good and then botom
is
out oh that's nice I can already feel
all the muscles that like move my legs
up and down waking up that feels
delightful next up we have this
one just to start getting me moving I
got a bad habit of only turning to one
side of my body so doing that exercise
gets me warmed up and ready to do turns
to both sides of my body and stretch out
my
sides there's kind of a variation of a
dance stretch but I just find that like
adding the weight of the POI really
helps to stretch out those intercostal
muscles on the side of you oh that feels
great I can just feel my entire body
opening up right now lovely so one of
the biggest places where I store stress
is definitely in the muscles that I used
to hold my thighs together so this next
exercise is totally centered around
trying to get me to like drop down and
release that muscle there we go so I
take curves around twice and the third
time take a
meltdown P it around boom and switch
directions and go back the other way oh
yeah now that's waking up down there so
real talk just like doing these
exercises and getting all these parts of
my body woken up it just like wakes me
up overall I feel much more alert I feel
much more active and interested in what
I'm doing
oh it's great all right so this next
one's kind of funky it is literally just
about building up and moving around
momentum so sh chass
to take
around under curves and over curves and
stop now I have to do it going the other
way pure wets take a meltdown around
under curves and over curves boom hey do
it
again take it
around keep that momentum going and that
gets the blood pump in if yall out there
have any interest in me doing a video
teaching the warm-ups that I use please
let me know down in the comments but I
am feeling really good right now my
whole body is warmed up and I feel a lot
less stressed and I feel a lot more
energized and ready to take on this next
project so so thanks for coming and
getting warmed up with me it really does
have to be said that when we Embrace a
movement art like Po or dance what we're
really doing is we're finding ways of
opening up our bodies and unlocking a
lot of that stress that we're holding on
to God only knows there's a lot of parts
of my body that have held on to stress
for years at a time and learning how to
move around more is really helpful for
me to be able to release that and just
be a happier human overall have you had
similar results with Po and dance let me
know down in the comments hey gang one
other quick note before let you loose
and that's to let you know that I'm
about to start up a new round of live
stream po dance classes these classes
are designed to take your PO dance to
the next level not only will I give you
in-depth instruction on a variety of
different po tricks and how to dance
them up we'll also talk about transition
points between different tricks and I'll
be giving you a piece of choreography
intended to bring all the different
pieces together you'll get to join a
community of Point answers from all
across the world flowing and growing
together registration is open now and
our first class is June 25th plus which
if you register before June 18th you
qualify for early bird tickets sign up
now at crowdcast doio drexfactor PO for
tuck turns Tango see you
[Music]
there this video of course would not be
possible without my amazing supporters
on patreon in particular I'd love to
give a shout out to my Flo patrons who
are listed on screen right now you all
totally Rock and if you out there
watching appreciate the content that I
make and you're not currently supporters
but you'd like to become supporters you
can do that by heading on over to my
patreon and signing up at
patreon.com Factor poy there's a host of
awesome rewards there so go check that
out please and thank you and if you're
curious how the other video that I'm
shooting today will work out I'll go
ahead and leave a link to it down in the
comments when it is posted publicly
thanks again for joining me make sure to
out and flow yourselves today and see
you with a new video real soon take care
now peace